bueno muchas gracias maría clara
obviamente es un paso lamentable pero
igualmente no sorprendente nicaragua
está siguiendo en los pasos de nicolás
maduro de venezuela que fue el primer
presidente en anunciar su retiro de la
oea en la historia de la organización
entonces es una forma de descalificar a
la comunidad de naciones de américa
latina y del caribe y obviamente sigue
el rechazo de la huella a las elecciones
del 7 de noviembre y una probabilidad
bastante importante que nicaragua sería
echado de de la hoya
invocando a la carta democrática que fue
aprobado en el 2001 entonces es una
muestra otra vez de la total ausencia de
la democracia de valores democráticos
de solidaridad regional usted habla de
una falta de democracia y esta es una de
las críticas pero también ha habido
críticas ante la falta de acciones de la
comunidad internacional como lo dijo en
este canal la ex presidenta de costa
rica laura chinchilla en ese sentido si
nicaragua se retira de la oea en que
quedaría entonces el control de la
comunidad internacional sobre lo que
ocurre en este país
bueno de hecho la comunidad
internacional tiene pocos instrumentos
tiene iniciativas diplomáticas tiene
sanciones que ya algunas han sido
impuestas por los estados unidos y tiene
la posibilidad de acercarse a daniel
ortega otros funcionarios del gobierno y
otros presidentes o cancilleres de la
región pero en él el hecho es que
pues te forma moral y ética la condena
de la hoya significa mucho
y en la práctica significa muy poco
desgraciadamente gracias señora garzón
por esta información